une impasse politique persistante qui ne
fait que confirmer les craintes du
président de la république tunisienne
alors que son premier ministre hichem et
chichi souhaite imposer onze nouveaux
ministres à l'issue du dernier
remaniement gouvernemental voilà qu'il
annonce aujourd'hui le limogeage de cinq
ministres les derniers proche du
président taille side une déclaration
qui ne fait que confirmer la stratégie
du premier ministre bien décidés à faire
valoir ses alliés notamment ceux du
parti islamiste ennahda
de son côté le président sayed compte
bien résisté jeudi il avait reçu au
palais de carthage
un groupe de députés de tous bords afin
de trouver une issue politique mais
surtout constitutionnel à cette nouvelle
crise au sommet de l'état
je m'adresse à nos détracteurs
aujourd'hui et depuis ce palais le
peuple et face à vous et j'en fais
partie
la constitution est derrière vous et je
suis le garant de son application
ils n'avaient nulle part où aller
le député at emilie qui était l'un
d'entre eux lors de sa visite au palais
de carthage avec neuf autres députés
leur semblait être à la contre attaque
autour du président qui n'a pas hésité à
parler de trahison
on a discuté la crise gouvernementale
pour le choix c'est un choix de
démarches de la nature du gouvernement
est un gouvernement de technocrates
complètement dépendant politiques pour
qu'ils trouvent que c'était entre
guillemets une trahison qui a été faite
par monsieur chi chi chi le considère
avoir conclu des accords relatifs mon
secret ils sont pas aussi ce qu'est que
ça parce que les les partis politiques
qui soutiennent shishir l'ont déjà
annoncé dès le début qu'ils allaient
procéder à un changement de la nature du
gouvernement de ses objectifs de manière
d'opérer pour le président de la
république ça c'est quelque chose
d'intolérable sur trois éthique sur le
plan de l'exemplarité par la part du
gouvernement mais c'est aussi une un
coup d'état par rapport à leur rotation
qu'il avait pour lesquels choisi
monsieur mechiche parmi les idées
proposées lors de cette réunion celle de
lancer un dialogue national seule
solution
sensuelle pour éviter un scénario
catastrophe personnellement j'avais
proposé un dialogue national
c'est la plate forme la base à partir de
laquelle on pourra définir un projet
pour le gouvernement pourra ainsi
définir nature une composition du
gouvernement mais aussi donner les
garanties
connaissant la crise financière cette
situation de crise ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui elle n'a fait qu'empirer
au cours de derniers mois un triste
constat selon nizar mcnee journaliste au
quotidien el sabah et analyste politique
pour lui depuis la révolution de 2011
l'écriture de la nouvelle constitution
adoptée en 2014
camille place à une république guide
semi parlementaire a favorisé la
multiplication des alliances partisanes
et contrarier la mise en place des
réformes nécessaires et l'alternance
politique la seule solution au delà des
solutions constitutionnel et de se
diriger vers un dialogue national fondé
sur trois volets politique économique et
social le plus important à l'heure
actuelle et le premier aspect à savoir
le politique car il est indispensable
d'opérer des changements en profondeur
de notre république semi parlementaire
qui s'est avéré incapable de résoudre la
crise que nous traversons
au contraire elle n'a fait qu'aggraver
la situation sans apporter aucune
solution qui pourrait profiter au peuple
et au pays dans son ensemble du
président de la république pour trouver
une sortie à cette crise politique
économique et gamble tout un pays de son
côté le premier ministre mais chichi
tente coûte que coûte de prouver la
constitutionnalité de ce remaniement
ministériel une situation chaotique
alors que le pays traverse une sombre
période de son histoire d'un point de
vue sanitaire économique mais également
sociales alors que plusieurs
portefeuilles restent vacants notamment
celui de l'intérieur du transport ou
encore de la santé